I said I'm alaikum guys how you doing I
have a very unique and interesting story
that I wanted to share with you guys and
insha'Allah we can derive some benefits
from it what's your name from Romania
Lilly and she's over here with some
friends from the also Jehovah's Witness
they're in the car here is Jehovah's
Witness we're at the gas station and
look how God sends the signs look at
that since I'm here now we're talking
back and forth and I'm getting to share
Islam the Quran Prophet Muhammad and all
these things don't happen by chance
so it's upon her me all of us when God
sends these signs and we talked when we
talk about the pure monotheism how God
Almighty sent messengers throughout time
we talked about the Quran how was the
last final Testament sent to mankind we
talked about the deep love Muslims have
for Jesus the preservation of the Quran
and the commonalities was that that we
we agreed how Jesus's whole life mission
was calling people to worship God not to
worship himself or any of creation we
touched upon a lot of things and I
thought that was really amazing at the
gas station put being gas and I was
given this watchtower then I shared I
hope you're gonna go to the gun show to
go to the Dean show so we've got to
share sharing is caring thank you for
sharing and God willing this is also our
friends here where this is there are
goals so they're out because they care
they're sharing and they came upon me
also what's up guys and this is their
Fred
Lily Lily I want you two to look up
Gabriel because she's from Romania and
the show I did with him was from Romania
no Jesus was not his name that's on
YouTube so it's with my friend your Brio
it's called Jesus inside his name
because that's something we agreed upon
that the English language didn't exist
so yes it was changed so look at Yeshua
Yeshua yes
so we talked about their gibreel he's
from Romania also check out that probe
we covered a lot but uh I I'm sharing
with my audience you know their name
because it's very unique to have we got
like this it's live like The Secret
Service yeah she came over and she came
to me and shared this so I they hooked
up with me and you know I had to share
also so hum did a lot you guys you might
have made my day all right thank you
guys peace so I'm at the gas station
pumping some gas very early and it's
very cold out so as I'm trying to get
into my car as the gas is pumping I hear
someone call out sir excuse me so my
first reaction is maybe someone needs
some money and as I turn around it was a
lady and it didn't look like she needed
any money because she had something in
her hand and she was she was telling me
can I she was asking if she could share
this with me and asked me a question so
I figured it out I said wow she has
something that she really believes in it
she wanted to share it with me
I said sure so go ahead and she asked me
a question said exactly what's on the
cover of this
it's called watchtower she said sir do
you believe does God care about us does
God care about you I said of course God
cares about us he created us he feeds us
he provides the air that we breathe he
nurtures us every day we're alive
we're benefiting from all the blessings
that the Creator has given us only
someone blind in the heart would not be
able to see these things and we went on
and on and we spoke so one of the
benefits is that you never know when
you're going to be given an opportunity
to share to do the Dawa and you've got
to be prepared you got to know the
basics of your Deen you know all the
football players names and the soccer
players names and their history but what
about when it comes down to your Deen
are you able to share it with certainty
with clarity are you able to articulate
the fundamentals of the clear message
that you live it's got to be so so
beloved to you that it just resonates
from inside your heart to your lips and
you you want to share it with people and
had a great opportunity here and one of
the things that I wanted to let you know
that you can go by to make it really
simple because every situation is unique
but if you remember the OMG oh my god if
you remember this all for oneness you
really want to talk about the first
thing is communicating to people the
oneness and that's what I did
communicating Touhey the oneness of your
Creator the pure monotheism then we get
into the messengership that the Creator
sent messengers out of his love he loves
us of course He loves us he cares about
us more than care he loves you more than
you're your own mother loves you and he
sent these messengers with guidance he
sent Abraham Noah Moses Jesus peace be
upon them all and Muhammad
peace and blessings be upon him the
final messenger with that same message
worship the one creator and don't
worship the creation and this is what we
find in the teachings of a snap now the
G is for the guidance then we got into
the Quran and all the proofs how it is
from the Creator it's it's been
preserved and we have it in its original
today and in the side and the prophecies
and you know you really only have at the
end of the day four possibilities when
it comes down to Prophet Muhammad and
the Quran either being from him himself
to it being from a group of people
nations coming together to produce this
Quran three its is it from the devil if
you knock all these three out at the end
you leave the person if they're sincere
and genuine to come to certainty and
without doubt that indeed this Quran
could not have come from the devil from
a group of men from the Prophet Muhammad
himself no but it came it was sent down
piecemeal over 23 years by the creator
of the human being out of God's love so
addressing the first question that he
had yes this is the ultimate love that
the creator has from us shown that he
sent the Prophet Muhammad as the final
messenger as a mercy to mankind and as
the and the Quran as a guidance for
humanity so we covered the OMG and I was
very happy that I was able to have this
inner counter these are Jehovah's
Witnesses and the second point that was
very important was their commitment
this is a small sect in Christianity but
they are producing the most results
results because they are the most
committed they're most committed you'll
see them on the bikes you'll see them
knocking on the doors you'll see them
like I did at the gas station cold
outside in the morning they're sharing
the message but let me ask you do they
have what we have of the Creator
addressing us in the verses like in
chapter 16 125 where you read them
you've read them you've heard them
although alas sabili replicable Hekmati
well no either till husana watch out in
humility here accent invite all to the
way of your Lord everyone it's a command
from your Creator from Allah do they
have this do they have verses like women
arsenic olamim and yellow law he wore me
la sala Helmick Allah in an eminent
muslimeen and who is better in speech
then that one that invites to Allah to
the Creator does righteous good deeds
and says I am of those who have
submitted to my lord
do they have these verses that you have
o Muslims do they have these do they
have the Prophet SAW some who is
commanding us for those who always have
some kind of excuse well I'm not that
knowledgeable I I don't have enough my
beards not long enough I don't have a
university degree from from this Medina
or as harder this than the other what
well do they have do they have these
Christians that they have the probably
saw something like we do telling us
convey from me even if it be one ayah
just one I look at that are you doing
that are we doing that do they have the
hadith for the prophets awesome Salinas
Mandela Allah hiya fella who me floette
Jennifer Ehle the one look at the ROI on
this on the Dow WA it's a stock that
continuously is rising and you don't
have to worry about balancing out the
good deeds Allah has got it all taken
care of for you
that the one who invites to something
good and what better good is there that
you're removing the [ __ ] you're removing
people away from something that will
land them into Jahannam
for eternity don't you care about your
neighbors your friends don't you care
about humanity so by removing the [ __ ]
helping them to guide them to the pure
monotheism to toe heed your helping is a
loss at saving one innocent human being
human life as if you saved the world
imagine helping to save one person from
Jahannam imagine that are you helping to
do that and you have to understand Allah
is not going to look at or is not
forcing you to make the results you are
the one just to plant the seed and a
lost want Allah is gonna make it grow
it's your efforts are we putting in the
effort to help share this message so
that's the number two benefit when you
look you got to commend them you got to
admire their dedication and the advice I
would have for for them because you are
I was also thinking about this and let
me get your guys thought leave it in the
comments below it was interesting
because this was a woman as a young
woman that they sent over to talk to me
because they know the psychology of man
they know what interest man
and I was thinking because I was like
when I asked I said where did you come
from I was kind of I've been wearing the
public area and everything I didn't
think that was appropriate when you had
two men who were more than ready and
able but maybe she was in training that
for her safety
you never know it's different maybe
you're accompanying with her you're
right next to her so they see another
man but even though they were not they
were in the car dressed up they look
like Secret Service not too far but
still I I would not advise them to go
ahead in today's society sick society
where you have all sorts of you know
someone can can do something in a matter
of seconds it's not safe it's different
you're with the woman and this is how we
value and honor the women in Islam that
we don't want to put them in any harm's
way if it was another woman all right we
can understand and this is the the thing
that I would bring to their attention to
be more mindful of this to protect and
to honor the woman and not even put her
in harm's potential harm's way and the
point for the sense of training or
whatever they're trying to do and and
and they know what they're doing with
the psychology of putting a woman out
there like that but to honor and to
cherish the woman in to to really to
consider this so I thought I share this
with you guys I thought this was very
interesting that's why I wanted to share
with you I hope you guys enjoyed this
and I hope we can derive these benefits
one always being ready having the
knowledge the basic knowledge and I gave
you guys a tip every situation is unique
and different but there's this where you
can go ahead and start off the OMG start
talking about the oneness of your
Creator the oneness of God the pure
monotheism the messengership
God Almighty send messengers and the
guidance that we have today Jehovah's
Witnesses are unique in their own way
they don't believe in the Trinity and
they still have the sonship so we
cleared these things up and you have in
the eye of Kahoolawe I had say he's God
the one and only the absolute the
eternal he begets not nor is He begotten
meaning that he's not the father of
anyone nor does he have any children nor
was he fathered and there is nothing
comparable to
to the Creator so you have all these
things you can share we we have so much
of the the lucid clear information out
there that goes with the heart that's
why Slav continues to be the fastest
growing way of life people get pushed
away from man-made religions because
they see the fingerprints of man all
over them it just doesn't make sense
things that are just out there they
don't connect with the human
intelligence and with the heart but I
challenge anyone to do the basic thing
in Islam and to look at the basic Creed
of Islam and do what we say will get you
to see things clearer and that's just
ask the Creator I always leave people
with this homework ask the Creator the
reality of all things the one who
created all things the one who created
the universe and everything in it you
don't have to give him a name say the
one who my Creator guided me guide me to
what the truth is because the reality is
that every 12 seconds in this country
where we're living someone is dying and
we're gonna die and we should really
reflect on what's the purpose of life if
this video is coming to you I mean this
is a sign and these are the signs that
come to us frequently can be daily but
we just refused to look into these
things so look into Islam and this is
something that left her and I also
pointed her in the direction because she
was from Romania and I pointed her in a
direction with one of my friends gibreel
who's also Romanian he accepted Islam
and this program that we did connecting
her with someone from her culture even
though she spoke fluent English but this
also helps to connect someone someone
who now will speak the same language she
speaks and understands the culture of
Romania and there's more of a connection
there that was the one thing that having
the knowledge being able to share it and
communicating it and then admiring
wrapping up admiring the Jehovah Witness
Christian's the passion that they have
that they're out there sharing because
they are committed and you have to
admire that
that was the other benefit and I want to
leave you with this story this is a
story that happened with with someone
else who was visited by Jehovah's
Witness and as the Jehovah's Witness
came to knock on their door the Muslim
invited a man
they had a nice conversation back and
forth and the Jehovah Witness didn't
have the kind of clarity to many of the
questions that come up in life
that Islam clearly addresses and lucidly
clearly without any ambiguities really
straightforward the evidence everything
is just so powerful overwhelming you're
just amazed and it leaves you speechless
and this Jehovah's Witness was less
speechless on the answers that the
Muslim was giving from from Islam but
then the Jehovah's Witness asked the
Muslim a question at the end that left
the Muslim speechless guess what that
question was and we'll conclude with
that did you think about it well let me
share it with you
he asked the Muslim if this if Islam is
providing all of these solutions and
it's so clear as it is and amazing as it
is and everything that you have stated
it just makes sense everything here that
you shared with me you believe in it's
so passionately Muslims believe is too
true so passionately he said Wyant they
out there sharing it like we are and the
Muslim was dumbfounded so that's the
last point of benefit we can take from
this story let us not be those who
believe in this Deen who lived this way
of life which passion with zeal but
we're not sharing it it's not our job to
convert people it's not our job to
change the hearts Allah is the one who
do that the Craters the one that will do
that but just to share if you care you
share and to get out there and share
this message help clear some of these
misconceptions and the least you can do
is direct them to the D show that's the
least thing you can do because we
addressed majority almost all of the
doubts the misconceptions the false
allegations people the stereotypes the
hype that people push out there against
Islam we've dressed almost all of these
things in the programs with many of our
special guests you can direct them to
the D show continue to tune in I hope
you enjoyed my experience that I had
and the benefits that we were able to
derive from it until next time peace be
with you send all day